(hip hop music)
- Hey everyone, my name is Jesse,
and today, I'm gonna
be testing four famous
celebrity brownie recipes, to see
which one is actually the best.
I'll be testing recipes
from Gordon Ramsay,
Guy Fieri, Ayesha Curry,
and Posh Spice herself, Victoria Beckham.
I measure out all the ingredients,
as the recipe states, to
level the playing field,
and I got three brownie
lovers in the office
to test them out in a blind taste test.
- Did someone say, "Brownies?"
- So, which celebrity has
the best brownie recipe?
Let's get baking.
Up first is Gordon Ramsay.
He starts by combining butter
and sugar in a large
bowl, and beating that
with electric mixer until
it's nice and fluffy.
To that, he adds melted chocolate,
and beats it again to combine.
It's kind of chunky, so
I gave it a few stirs.
To that, add salt, vanilla extract,
cocoa powder, and flour, and
mix that all up, until smooth.
Add some eggs.
Mix it again until it
gets nice and fudgey.
Add some milk, if it needs to
be thinned out a little bit.
And then you're gonna add a
shit ton of dried cherries.
Seriously, a lot of dried cherries.
Pour that into a lined baking tin.
Smooth it out, so it bakes nice and even.
And pop it in the oven.
Once baked, put some edible glitter,
Pop Rocks, and sprinkles on top
because you know, regular
brownies aren't enough.
- This is like a child's
imagination of space.
It looks like a kid's brownie.
- Oh God, it crunched.
- What the heck did I just bite into?
- Oh my God, is that Pop Rocks?
- Oh, that's really weird.
There's something else in here.
- This is cherry instead of chocolate?
That's good.
Cherries in brownies are a 100% yes.
- Ugh, the fruit.
- It's pretty good.
Just leave the cherries on the side.
Otherwise, pretty freaking
delicious. (smacks lips)
- [Jesse] Guy Fieri starts by combining
cut rhubarb, water, and
sugar, in a large pot,
and cooking it down 'til it
turns into a nice compote.
Meanwhile, you're gonna
combine chili powder,
salt, flour, cinnamon, and baking powder,
and sift that all, so
there is no chunks in it.
Set that aside, then
combine butter, white sugar
and beat that together
with electric beaters
until it's nice and fluffy.
Add some eggs, and continue beating it
until it gets even fluffier.
Add rum, vanilla extract,
and then bring back
that compote you made, and
add melted chocolate to it.
Stir it together.
It'll look kinda weird,
but add it to the eggs,
and fold that in, until
it's nice and sweet.
Add some flour, and fold it again
until it's nice, fudgy, and
looks like a nice batter.
Add chocolate and walnuts,
and stir it once more.
Bring in a pan that you
lined with parchment paper.
Put it in there, and pop it in the oven.
There you have it.
Brownies, that'll take you
straight to Flavor Town.
- The crust on top is beautiful.
I can really figure out my life,
just looking at this crust.
- Mmm!
Yes!
- There's some kind of
like, cinnamon in it.
It doesn't really taste like a brownie.
And it doesn't have the
texture of a brownie.
It's more of like, a cake.
- You can hear how sticky,
and like, moist this
brownie is, just listen.
- [Jesse] Up next, is Ayesha Curry,
with her horchata brownies.
She starts by combining
butter and chocolate chips
in a double boiler, so
it gets nice and melted.
Take that off the heat, add white sugar,
brown sugar, give that a stir,
and add four eggs.
Add salt, cinnamon, flour.
Stir that up again, 'til
it's nice and fudgy.
Then, add slivered
almonds, and fold that in.
Pour it into a prepared pan.
Smooth it out, and pop in the oven.
As it's cooking, get
some rice milk reducing,
pour it into a bowl, add rum, cinnamon,
give it a stir, and add a shit ton of
powdered sugar to it, so it
turns into nice, glossy glaze.
Take your brownies out.
Pour that glaze over,
and smooth it out.
It'll harden in a few
hours, and it's good to go.
- This looks like a brownie
with lots of makeup.
Gorgeous.
- Mmm.
- Ooh, I like this.
Not your classic brownie,
but you still get
all the elements of a brownie in it.
- I'm very confused,
because this tastes amazing.
It just doesn't taste like a brownie.
- Oh, I really like whatever's on top.
It's like, reminds me of
like, an apple crumble.
- I can't decide, I'm sorry.
- This is pretty good.
I wish she had some kind of crunch to it,
but as is, beautiful.
- Thumbs up for this one.
- [Jesse] Victoria Beckham starts by
combining sugar, cocoa
powder, and melted butter
in a bowl, and stir in all together.
Add vanilla extract, four eggs,
and give that a good stir
until it's nice and fudgy.
Add some baking powder, salt, flour,
give it another good stir,
and the batter is it.
Posh keeps it nice and simple.
Bring your pan in.
Pour it in.
Spread it out, so it
bakes nice and evenly,
and pop it in the oven.
Now, you're baking like Beckham.
- This looks like the brownie I know.
- If you asked me to make a brownie,
like, this is what I would make.
- This is not very crunchy.
It's just like (splats).
- Mm-mm.
I don't like this one.
- It's definitely a little drier.
- Whoever made this, are you on a diet?
What's up?
I'm missing my butter.
I'm missing my chunks of chocolate.
- It's not chocolatey enough.
- [Jesse] So, which celeb
has the best brownies?
Let's find out.
- This is what you guys
have all been waiting for.
The best celebrity brownie is number one.
I never would have thought to put cherries
in a brownie, and it tasted really good,
'cause there's like, chocolate and fruit
as a mixture, is always great.
Ah, Gordon Ramsay, of course!
- Out of these four brownies, I think
my favorite is number three.
It had those elements
of a classic brownie.
It was gooey, the flavors
developed within it.
Ooh, I like that!
- My favorite is definitely number two.
The combination between soft and crunch
was so amazing, and I'm always
looking forward to that.
Totally see this being his creation.
- [Director] Kevin, we need
you to be the tie breaker.
- Who, me?
I really don't like this one.
I like that one a lot.
I thought I liked it for a second.
Number two is definitely my favorite.
I'm a new fan of Guy Fieri, I guess.
(triumphant horn music)
- [Jesse] So, there you have it.
Guy Fieri has the best brownies.
Which celebrity recipes would
you like us to try next?
Hit us up in the comments.